(sifflement de train)
- Nous sommes en plein milieu
du déser
à une heure de la frontière
mexicaine.
De nulle part surgit ce magasin
Prada. Rien n'est à vendre.t t t
qui annonce la particularité de
Marfa.
♪ ♪ ♪
On comi i i i pas moins de
19 galeries d'art et
d'exposition. Pas mal pour
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est ici que s'est installé
il y a 15 ans l'artiste
Julie Speed.
Elle expose et vend ses toiles
un peu partout aux États-Unis,r.
Marfa, l'Artistique,
vit aussi la nuit.
Comme ici, dans les ténèbr......
(trompette)
Rob Mazurek, un musicien de
Chicago, qui joue un peu
dans le monde, a lui aussi
choisi la ville texane de Marfa.
tous ces artistes à Marfa?
Tout a commencé il y a 50 ans,
désaffectée, dont on ne peut pas
vraiment vou
grand-chose.
Car toute image est soumise
ututututututututeur par
la fondation Chinati, qui gère
l'héritage artistique de Donald
new-yorkais, dont les créations.
Ainsi, à Marfa, on chuchote
se définit comme artiste.
MAGALIE GUÉRIN, artiste peintre
- Bon, je vis dansuauauauauauaue
dans le désert.
Ça m'impressionne tellement.
Magalie Guérin.
- C'est un gros
surtout pour quelqu'un
qui a toujours déménagé
T'sais, quand je dis
"New York" : "Ah, New York!
OK." Après ça, "Chicago" :
"Ah Chicago!". Et pu
♪ ♪ ♪
- Artiste d'art abstrait,
c'est après une résidence
au sein de la fondation Chinati
qu'elle a décidé de s'établir
- Moi, j'ai l'impression
que c'est nécessaire pour
chaque artiste de venir iciMainn
nécessairement d'être da
les grandes villes pour faire
partie de la conversation.
Bon, l'idée que la vie peut être
un petit peu plus... plaisante,
simple, belle, au niveaumumumum?
Là-dessus, ces résidentss's's'si
en 2018, les couleurs de mess s.
ueueueueueueueueueueueueueueueu♪
où la culture survit et rayonne.
♪ ♪